the tampa bay rays tonight it's going to
be left-hander ryan yarbrough making his
fourth start of the season sixth overall
appearance and looking to build off of
his last outing where he worked really
as the bulk guy five and two thirds
three hits no runs six strikeouts and
just one walk you will not see many
fastballs from tonight's starter ryan
yarbrough
although he does throw one there to
michael brantley and michael sends it
right back to center field for a base
hit oh brantley who had a 3 45 average
on the last home stand continues where
he left off at home with a single his
first time up on this road trip the
fastball as you see on our match from
super mo at 86 miles an hour it's it's
not not going to beat guys i guarantee
you michael brownlee was probably
sitting off speed but recognized
fastball and pulled the hands in fast
enough to get the barrel to it astros
playing in the east coast time zone for
the first time since 2019. good to see
jordan alvarez back in there
there's a ball hit hard in the left
field and that'll be down for a hit
jordan alvarez after missing two games a
single to left michael brantley going
first to third and the astros two
left-handers have hits against
yarborough tonight how about michael
brantley getting a good jump and taking
off there's that cutter it's up and
we've actually seen jordan one of his
home runs was a pitch up out over the
plate that he went the other way with
that power but it has been pretty simple
for him this year just to get on top of
the baseball and shoot it the other way
for a base hit i'll bring up carlos
correa coming in batting 277 four home
runs a dozen rbis
correa first pitch swinging line drive
base hit into the left center astros on
the board first brantley scores jordan
alvarez going first to third carlos
correa driving in his 13th run of the
year it's one nothing houston it's good
to see the astros getting off to a quick
start i feel like if they can go out and
get themselves some runs early it would
allow lance mccullers to relax a little
bit as you see carlos correa take that
cutter in and just move it into left
field for that rbi base hit the astros
running the bases incredibly well and
scoring early just so it could give
lance a little more comfort relaxation
bottom of the first inning lance
mccullers jr on the mound for the astros
one and one with a 4.58 ra in four
starts i guess the native of tampa
florida just
across the bay just north of st
petersburg where tropicana field is
located well now manuel marco and boy
what a series he had in that alcs had a
great postseason
ground ball base hit the other way into
right
tucker makes the pickup out there and
manuel margot is aboard that's one of
those instances where the defense
doesn't line up with the pitch and the
location you've got everybody pulled
around and then the fastball
is about thigh high on the outer half
that makes it real easy for manuel
margot to see it well and just it just
hits the ground ball the other way it's
going to be a base hit nothing they can
do about it there's 01.
runner on the move the throw down to
second in time margot thrown out trying
to steal a base
what a throw by the machete gunning him
down for out number two
not entirely sure was that a straight
steal it was a delayed steal a couple of
shuffles and then go trying to catch the
astros
sleeping a little bit but not the
machete he was ready to fire and gunned
down margot good play all the way around
sometimes you can catch that middle
infielder sleeping but correa did a
great job of reading that the slider his
new toy so why not go back to it there
we go swing and a miss gandhi diaz who
doesn't normally leave the zone chases
that one as lance mccullers jr picks up
his first strikeout and gets through the
first inning cenino batting in the
number six spot tonight for kevin cash
see what he does here the one-two pitch
swing and a miss one with the fastball
and i think he wanted that one elevated
too but it was down and zanino swings
through it and that is mccullar's second
strikeout that's what astro fans are
accustomed to seeing that swing and miss
but that was a good fastball down after
throwing off speed early slowing things
down a little bit and then just pump the
heater past zanino so now mccullars will
face kevin kiermeier
swaying in a miss mccullar strikes out
kiermeier gets back-to-back strikeouts
to end the second three strikeouts in
the game here's michael brantley
brantley with a single to run scored his
first time up
here it is again and brantley
what a professional hitter he is it
doesn't matter what you throw him he is
ready to hit as he hits a base hit to
right field he's two for two tonight and
that is not an easy pitch lefty on lefty
yeah this is it's like nadal playing
tennis
he kind of recognizes where it's gonna
be puts the foot down and casually says
okay i'm gonna attack it then gets that
top spin to get over the shift of the
second baseman out there in shallow
right field and plants it in between
both the right fielder and second
baseman that was beautiful alex has the
entire right side of the infield open
with michael brantley being held on and
three
of the four infielders on the third base
side
bregman drives one deep to left field
forget about it alex bregman connects on
his fourth home run of the year
he makes it a three-nothing astros lead
he timed that beautifully and laid off a
couple of pitches up in the zone if you
remember two pitches ago there was an
off-speed pitch up
he took kind of asked the home plate
umpire where was that is at the top of
your zone but all through those first
two at bats you could feel he was kind
of gauging where yarbrough was at and
got a pitch he could handle and
absolutely destroyed it a changeup
yanked middle middle stayed back and
pummeled it 103 miles an hour off the
bat
putting the astros up and here's jordan
alvarez
3-2 pitches a rocket into center field i
mean that was scalded caremeyer barely
makes the play on it it got to him so
quickly he was like an infielder he had
to chest it up i am looking forward to
the exit velo on that one bloomer 114.7
miles an hour off the bat we have to
slow it down on our mattress from
supermoto watch this scud go back up the
middle
my goodness yeah i ate up kiermeier
about 350 feet away yeah there's
infielders that take longer to get a
ground ball than that got the gear so
here's carlos correa rbi single his
first time up
correa slicing one down the line that'll
be a fair ball and bounces over the
short wall there and right jordan was
thinking about trying to score from
first which in and of itself is a good
side
as carlos correa doubles the other way
and the astros have four consecutive
hits against yarbrough
trying to stay back on this cut fastball
he does just kind of slices underneath
it a little bit as it comes off the
label
here we go fourth inning baseball
martine maldonado will lead things off
against ryan yarborough and maldonado
down the left-field line hooking off the
wall bounds away from meadows mounted
out on the second does he have a chance
to go to third he's digging for three
maldi head first slide safe miracles
happen we're all witnesses maldi's got
to have that bench in tears right now
because a triple is not what you're
expecting
from martin maldonado he ripped this one
down that left field line it just stayed
barely it almost got out of here with
that short wall in left field but as
meadows was heading towards it it
bounced away and full head of steam
martine is not going to be denied so
michael brantley will try and continue
his fine night he's already two for two
with a couple of singles and a couple of
runs now he could drive one in if he
finds some
open space in the outfield
brantley in the left center field have
yourself a knight michael brandley rbi
single he's three for three and it's
five nothing in the fourth he's such a
good hitter a couple of base hits
earlier in this game up the middle to
that pull side and this one he let's
travel
and just shoots the other way to get
that rbi driven in in his third hit on
the evening if his father mickey is in
town the hitting coach will just say
well done son see if lead miss diaz can
cash in with a two out rbi he hits the
ground ball past the diving low into
right field rbi single for diaz it's now
a six to nothing game second run batted
in on the night for a lead miss got him
fired up tk talking about his five hit
game and he went out there and attacked
that first pitch fastball hit it hard it
was just a matter of was he going to be
able to get it past lau who laid out
trying to keep that run from scoring and
couldn't he has mike cenino who he
struck out twice
swing and a miss he's got
zanino for the third time tonight lance
now up to eight strikeout and there's
one away in the seventh inning almost
feels personal what lance mccullers was
doing to cenino after that post-season
home runs that he had against him he
came out here struck him out in that
first time with the fastball and then
went change up change up to get swings
over the top from zanino three into the
count
and a miss lance mccullers jr finishes
off the night seven innings of three hit
shutout baseball he strikes out nine
and he'll leave with the astros leading
six to nothing
two minute scoring position for lebanese
diaz he has two rbis and a single led
miss diaz has a line dry base hit diaz
adds to his rbi total bregman scores
correa scores a four rbi night for a led
miss diaz it is eight nothing in the
ninth inning astros are playing a full
team game
willie adams but the rays have now gone
two for 48 with the runners in scoring
position
fly ball center field that's going to
drop for a base hit
wendell scores here comes zanino across
the plate
and adamus drives in two with a base hit
the reigns avoid the shutout
and get a hit with men in scoring
position andre scrub night making his 21
debut giving up a couple of runs here in
the ninth inning now trying to finish
off the game and it's a called third
strike he dropped in the curveball for
the final out astros win 9-2
with 15 hits